hey guys it's joanna here so you have
been eating really well track every
single calorie spent many hours in the
gym you have pretty much done everything
right and healthy but the belly fat just
will not go away so if you want to know
why and how you can start shifting those
fat away from your midsection then be
sure to watch this video through i'm
going to get into the science behind it
and also offer you practical steps on
how to lose belly fat
to simply put belly fat equals hormones
plus lifestyle so if both of them are
imbalanced that's when you will start to
lose belly fat if either one is out of
balance that's when the fat will start
to be stored around the mid section okay
belly fat can also mean high insulin
levels high cortisol low estrogen and
low progesterone one of the most common
reasons why we struggle to lose belly
fat is due to stress when i talk about
stress i'm not just talking about
emotional stress this include your
sleeping habit exercise routine and also
food habits so let's take a look at
stressful lifestyle when you're stressed
out it can lead to mindless overeating
and you tend to crave for high fat high
calorie and high sugar food and that is
just one part of the equation to make
matter worse your body will pump out
more cortisol which enlarges the fat
cells increase appetite and this
promotes your body to store fat around
the belly area okay if you're a thin
woman struggling from belly fat you have
to understand that it comes down to
stress management it is not how much you
eat how little exercise you do or
because you're consuming too much carbs
it really comes down to stress so the
next time you're stressed out instead of
grabbing high fat high calorie junks
try deep breathing for two minutes
meditate or go for long walks i
personally find that taking two minutes
of deep and conscious breaths really
help with my stress level
next lack of sleep if you sleep less
than 6 hours every night and you're
constantly feeling tired you're also
putting your body under stress which
means higher cortisol levels lack of
sleep also increases ghrelin a hormone
that stimulates appetite which means you
may consume more high fat and high sugar
foods in a day so aim to sleep between
seven to nine hours every night stay
away from caffeine in the evening and
put away all your electronic devices one
hour prior to your sleep keep your room
cool and dark to ensure that you get a
good rest the next really important
point to look at is extreme dieting when
you're constantly feeling hungry and
you're constantly depriving your body
from food you're also putting extreme
stress onto your body so eating less and
expecting a flat belly long term would
not work the hunger hormone ghrelin is
also a fat storing hormone so if you're
someone who practices eating less and
exercising more yes you may lose to it
temporarily but unintentionally you're
increasing your growling and also fat
storing potential so once you resume to
normal eating you will find that your
body puts on fat very quickly and that
is why i'm against any quick weight loss
solution or restricted dieting because
it is not sustainable and it will only
cause damage to your body long term
there are two ways to approach this eat
less exercise less or eat more exercise
more both these methods will still
generate calorie deficit for you to lose
weight but enough fuel to keep energy
hunger and cravings stable so i would
encourage you to watch my the science
behind burning belly fat video here for
you to understand each method in more
details the next point to look at is
wrong kind of training so what do i mean
by that you're a cardio bunny and that's
all you do you do not include strength
training into your routine you
diligently perform 100 crunches every
day hoping that the belly fat would melt
away you do a very light workout and
assume that that's enough effort
so let's look at cardio cardio is very
important and should be part of your
exercise routine but doing cardio alone
is not enough your body stops burning
fat right after your cardio exercise you
have to include strength training and
also high intensity training that's
because what you'll do is that you will
increase your metabolic rate and your
body will continue to burn fat even
after the workout while at rest saying
that however you shouldn't be performing
high intensity training every single day
because over exercising can also put too
much stress onto your body so you may
struggle to sleep at night feel
lethargic tired agitated increase in
appetite and all these can be
counterproductive so my suggestion is to
include two days of strength training
two days of high intensity training and
two days of moderate to low intensity
training it is also very important to
remember that we cannot spot reduce fat
okay
which means doing 1 000 or 100 crunches
every single day will not melt the belly
fat to reduce belly fat you have to
reduce your total
body fat percentage so just to give you
an idea a lean belly is about 10 body
fat for meal and 20 body fat for female
at the moment i am about 20 body fat so
belly fat is also associated with
inflammation highly processed food
refined grains sugar and fried foods
such as chips cakes and crackers or soda
drinks can cause inflammation in the
body making the belly to appear larger
than it should be these foods also cause
your insulin level to spike aka the fat
storing hormone and encourages your
liver to store fats around the belly
area so even if you're on a low calorie
diet but your diet consists mainly of
junk foods you will still struggle to
shift the fat away from your belly
because remember guys not all calories
are equal it is not about going on a low
calorie diet or you know counting every
single calorie but more importantly it
is about eating the right calorie to
burn fat and to get a flat tummy the
easiest step to take right now is to cut
on all chunks and you will see the
difference in just one week
eat more natural foods that fight
against inflammation such as green leafy
vegetables berries ginger turmeric
healthy fats from salmon nuts and seeds
all these foods will aid your digestion
burn stubborn belly fat and make your
belly appear less bloated and the final
factor which we will all eventually need
to deal with is aging as we age our body
starts to change as well reduced in
metabolic rates less efficient in
burning fat and it is more challenging
to lose weight and tone up so for the
ladies weight skin around the meat
section is extremely common especially
after menopause our estrogen levels drop
dramatically causing fat to be stored
around the midsection so when you're
older you wouldn't need as much energy
compared to your younger days so if you
were to eat like your younger days you
will start to gain weight once you hit
your 40s or 50s you need to make changes
to your eating habits eat slightly
lesser and consume between 4 to 5
smaller meals a day
doing low impact exercises such as
vigorous yoga will also help to reduce
belly fat do watch my changes to your
body at 20 to 70 to really understand
how age plays a huge role and what you
can do about it
so these are few factors on why you're
not losing belly fat remember that belly
fat equals hormones plus lifestyle so
your lifestyle will influence your
hormone levels as much as most of us
would want a flat belly to look good in
the beginning
i'm not promoting that we should all aim
for six packs and a really lean looking
tummy because a little bit of fat can
help to protect your organs but too much
of fat around the midsection can cause
many health issues such as
cardiovascular diseases diabetes and
even cancer
so if you enjoy this video if you find
this video to be really helpful
do like this video share this video and
subscribe to my youtube channel for more
recipes
health tips and also exercises all the
best
[Music]
you